hi folks I'm drew Carey as you know I'm  from Cleveland Ohio I love Cleveland  Ohio I based my whole career of being  from cream in Ohio and he also might  know that Cleveland Ohio has gone  through some tough times right now the  economy is in trouble  schools are in trouble and people have  been leaving the city in droves for a  long long time  and it's not just Cleveland it's a lot  of cities in the country or having the  same problems I went to the folks at The  Reason Foundation I said is there any  way we can come up with some ideas to  help save Cleveland and we looked at  some best practices at other cities  around the country and we wanted to know  if we applied him to Cleveland would it  do any good the series is called the  reason saves  you